eine nebenwirkung der ukraine krise ist
sicher dass mit der absurd teuren
energie plötzlich ist die
nebenkostenabrechnung der natürliche
feind des deutschen mieters ja der
gaspreis hat sich innerhalb eines jahres
mehr als verdoppelt
heizöl ist 65 prozent teurer wobei da
natürlich wie immer verschiedene
ursachen zusammen kommen die die nach
corona erwachenden märkte in asien zum
beispiel die co2 bepreisung ich würde
sagen um das wirklich zu kapieren da
brauchst der echte fachleute man muss ja
sehen dass die energiepreise getrieben
werden stark durch die knappheit beim
gas und steigende energiepreise
verstehen sie die energiepreise werden
getrieben von steigenden energiepreisen
da merkst du direkt der mann hat bwl
studiert hat er gar nicht politik und
philosophie das tut mir leid übrigens
kassiert der staat ja immer fröhlich mit
allein durch energie und stromsteuern
landen dieses jahr voraussichtlich rund
1,4 milliarden mehr in der kasse von
christian lindner als 2021
glückwunsch noch im august hat übrigens
ein mann gleichen namens von der groko
gefordert die stromsteuer zu senken aber
gut kann man nicht vergleichen der ware
eine opposition jetzt ist es sein geld
energiekosten sind der große
inflationstreiber und nach und nach
trifft das wirklich jedes produkt auch
die wichtigsten all diese faktoren ob
die diese preiserhöhung ist ob wir die
gewürze sind objekte gas es wird alles
teurer die ware wird dadurch teurer ist
ein kreislauf der sich da an gibt und
durch diesen kreislauf werden wir also
den können wir nicht standhalten dann
müssen wir natürlich die körpers opera
machen so jetzt reicht's ab jetzt ist es
nicht mehr lustig currywurst mal teurer
vielen dank auch wir leben wirklich in
verrückten zeiten warmduscher ist längst
keine beleidigung mehr sondern ein
kompliment warm duschen sind iris hobby
für für reiche leute
während ärmere haushalte natürlich
überproportional leiden wer zum beispiel
unter 1300 netto verdient gibt gerade
rund zehn prozent seiner konsumausgaben
für wohnen energie aus machen das ändert
alles sogar bei der partnerwahl
du bist single ist und sich nach unten
für den nebenkosten kein problem sind
energie partner.de die dating-plattform
mit der du endlich den traum typen
findest der sich eine warme wohnung
leisten kann und zwar so warm wie immer
du willst mit fußbodenheizung
er hat einfach alles sogar
elektrisches licht
heißen singles aus seiner nachbarschaft
wollen die reinheit
sex oder energie partner denn wahr ist
das neue sexy
sehr verstört von den 1,4 milliarden
mehr steuern durch energie muss die
ampel den bürger viel mehr zurückgeben
im sommer kriegen wohngeld empfänger
studenten oder azubis eine einmalzahlung
135 euro für singles 175 für paare aber
das ist quasi einen tropfen auf den
kalten steinen sagen sozialverbände
rentner zum beispiel gucken da komplett
in die röhre alles nachzulesen in dem
buch der 100 jährige der aus dem fenster
stieg um sich aufzuwärmen weil es
draußen wärmer ist als drinnen nur mal
zum vergleich frankreich investiert
gerade acht milliarden allein um die
strompreise niedrig zu halten so geht
das es gibt ja forderungen die sagen
vollständige übernahme der heizkosten
für menschen in hartz 4 oder mit ganz
kleinen renten wäre das etwas
vollständige übernahme liegt immer dazu
ein das man dann die heizung auftritt
und das fenster aufmacht sozusagen das
sollte schon ein anreiz geben sorgsam
mit energie umzugehen ja ja klar den
harzer musste zur sorgsamkeit entziehen
sonst dreht er durch na dann dann heizt
er seinen mit schampus gefüllten jacuzzi
konstant auf 30 grad man ahnt was er
ungefähr meint aber sehr unglücklich
formuliert da lobe ich mir doch den
britischen anbieter wo energy der hat
gerade in england vorgemacht dass es
auch deutlich sensibler geht hat sich
doch der energieversorger energie schon
vor ein paar tagen für einen kunden
brief entschuldigt darin forderte er
kunden auch mit einem haustier zu
kuscheln oder zu springen um sich warm
zu halten
mannomann wie bitte jetzt wird schon
offen zur sexuellen belästigung von
hunden aufgerufen wo ist martin rütter
wenn man immer braucht wir fassen
zusammen wenn demnächst wegen co2
bepreisung alles noch teurer wird im
energiesektor muss endlich signifikant
was zurückfließen an den verbraucher
viele familien knappsten ja jetzt schon
wo es nur geht die wird rechts zum
beispiel
alexander wipprecht macht sich sorgen
seit tagen steht er am gaszähler und
sieht sein geld verschwinden es ist also
klar ganz ohne warmwasser geht es
natürlich nicht aber wenn bettina schon
mal warten muss dann macht eben auch das
abwaschen und
natürlich muss man nicht jeden raum
heizen aber je nachdem wofür er
gebraucht wird
alles klar mama ja das können sie alles
noch aus schlesien insofern
hey cool
fordert
aber was auch cool ist und gar keinen
strom verbraucht malefiz
6 läuft familie wipprecht beweist wenn
alle mitmachen sind sie jetzt rekord
energiepreise kein problem
und das sei ja toll ist weil wir darin
kaum noch strom verbrauchen kann ich
guten gewissens meinen tesla aufladen
mit denen hier gibt es übrigens 6000
euro von guten onkel herbert von wegen
geistige regierung
das was in der schule
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk